قابل فرحات ، يمكن أن يكون
المستقبل وبقوة 5 جرام لديه فرصة في
مجال الروبوتات هي شركة سويدية
تصنع روبوتات اجتماعية ، فهي تحتاج إلى سرعات 5 جرام
لرفع اختراعها إلى المستوى التالي
جزء كبير من الروبوتات في السحب
و  جزء كبير من التفاعل مع
الروبوت هو أنه يجب أن يكون سريعًا حقًا ،
أعني أن البشر ليس لدينا الكثير من الصمت
عندما نتحدث مع بعضنا البعض أو
نستعين بمساعدة خوارزمية معقدة
لتشغيلها تتطلب
سرعات فائقة لتكرار الإنسان  التفاعل
وإظهار رمز الاستجابة السريعة للكاميرا في
صدري ،
لقد وجدت عملية الشراء الخاصة بك
على عكس الروبوتات الأخرى ، تم تصميم فرحات
لتوفير تجربة محادثة غنية
يمكنك التحدث والاستماع إلى إظهار العاطفة
والحفاظ على مطوري التواصل
البصري ، ويقول مطورو فرحات إنه يمكن أن يوفر
الرفقة لخدمة العملاء
والموظفين المدربين و  حتى أنه يقوم بتدريس لغة ما ، لذلك
يكتب التعاطف أن التأثيرات العاطفية للربط بين
هذه الأشياء هي ما تفتقر إليه
التكنولوجيا اليوم وما يتبقى
لدى البشر مما يجعل  نريد أن
نتفاعل مع بعضنا البعض إذا كان بإمكاننا بناء
تقنية يمكن للناس الوثوق بها حقًا
ويريدون التفاعل معها ، فإن
5g مثيرة للغاية ستوفر سرعات تصل إلى
مائة مرة أسرع من 4G والروبوتات
ليست الوحيدة التي تعتمد على 5g
ألق نظرة  حول هذه الغرفة ، سيارات ذاتية القيادة ،
واقع افتراضي ، طائرات بدون طيار ذاتية القيادة ،
حتى الإجراءات الجراحية التي يمكن تشغيلها على 5g ،
هذه الشركات في دبي كجزء من
معرض اتصالات 5G ، كانت شركة الاتصالات التي تتخذ من الإمارات العربية المتحدة مقراً
لها ، أول شركة في
المنطقة تطلق الشبكة
التي نقدم حلولاً لها
للنقل  لقد أعطتهم
حلول حلول الرعاية الطبية للأعمال المالية وتجارة
التجزئة مع أنشطة
استخدام 5g الأميال الإضافية
للاستفادة من هذه التكنولوجيا ، حسنًا ،
سريعًا ، سأطلب منك خلال
أسئلة الاختيار من متعدد حيث يصبح الوصول إلى 5g أكثر
سهولة في جميع أنحاء العالم.
التكنولوجيا التي تأتي معها تجعلنا
نحقق هذا النجاح ، فأنت تعلم بنفس
الطريقة التي تمتلك بها هاتفًا ذكيًا أنت في
جعبتك  سيكون لديك طريق اجتماعي
فوق هذا كل شيء وأنت تعلم أن
هذا هو حلمنا في جعل الروبوتات
مثل قبعة الفراء البشرية ، لا بأس
بالتحدث إلى
كلاكما وداعًا الآن هذه السي إن إن
[موسيقى]